[Musique]
dans tous les pays où une forme de
passeports vaccinale a été imposée les
façon frauduleuse de contourner cet
outil se sont multipliés mais ce qui a
plus récemment capter notre attention
c'est la présence de publicité sur le
web faisant miroiter la possibilité
d'acheter un passeport vaccinale
carrément un code qr créé de toutes
pièces une façon de bénéficier des
privilèges associés aux passeports
vaccinale tout en évitant de se faire
vacciner ça c'est ce qui est promis mais
qu'en est il vraiment
on a reçu un courriel cette semaine
d'une lectrice madame claire pagé qui a
vu passer une publicité facebook elle
dit j'ai vu sur facebook une publicité
de médecins pour la liberté qui vous
offre une attestation vaccinale s'agit
de celle d'une attestation pour ino
vacciner est il possible qu'ils se
procurent des codes qr par ce genre
d'organisation cela m'inquiète donc on
va aller faire un tour sur facebook voir
de quel peuple par madame pagé et
inspecté un peu ce qui se passe avec sa
tombe est un peu dans le terreau de
terreau du dup et un mixeur
donc on avait que sur facebook on peut
les voir la page médecin pour la liberté
et on voit effectivement que cette page
le elle a plusieurs publications où elle
dit vendre des faux passeports sanitaire
des faux codes qr donc ici on a un code
qr pour la france qui se vend pour 200
euros et on arrive à la publication
suivantes ont dû vendre des attestation
valide sans aucune injection
pour le code qr québécois dont baxi code
pour 300 dollars ça dit contacter les
gens derrière la page un numéro de
téléphone whatsapp bien leur écrire un
courriel madame page et je vous rassure
et un code qr comme seul on peut pas
l'acheter on peut pas falsifié le code
qr québécois parce que ce code qr la
s'inscrit dans un système standardisé
internationale qui s'appelle
et ses codes qr le doivent être cynique
négativement par les gouvernements qui
les émettent ça veut dire que personne
peut créer un code qr comme celui là et
le faire approuver par l'application au
bac cicad very fonction scan info code
qr ce serait tout simplement rejetés
donc on peut dire que ça avec certitude
on peut dire que c'est une arnaque puis
avec l'outil transparence la page même
voir que les deux administrateurs de la
page médecin pour la liberté sont
établis au cameroun dont il ya deux
administrateurs au cameroun aucun autre
administrateur de pages donc des gens au
cameroun qui vendent des faux codes qr
québécois on peut se dire il ya des
chances que c'est une arnaque ont
compressé de faire c'est de contacter
légendaire la page et voir exactement
c'est quoi leur modus operandi
je vais leur envoyer un message sur
what's up
je leur écris rebonjour que j'aimerais
acheter un code qr
québécois
comment ça fonctionne
donc je me demande à ce que ce réseau là
va plus loin que juste médecin la
liberté je vais utiliser un outil qui
s'appelle dont une pause pour aller voir
si les gens derrière ce site la recette
d'autres sites web
on peut voir qu'il ya une quinzaine de 7
enregistrée avec l'adresse courriel qui
a enregistré le site de médecins pour la
liberté notamment le isildur1 qui
s'appelle animaux pour la vie.com donc
on va les voir qu'est-ce que ce site
animaux pour la vie star site qui
ressemble quand même ben c'est un site
qui nous propose d'adopter des animaux
de compagnie ce étrange que des gens qui
vendent des passeports sanitaire propose
aussi d'adapter les animaux de compagnie
jours c'est mon répondeur och oui ont
répondu
qu'ils gravent ses 400 dollars pour un
pain sanitaire mais 5 à 1500 dollars
donc c'est quand même chemin alors quel
bac 5 à 0 $ si vous voulez aller
chercher
je répondrais cette année vendre je leur
ai demandé donc vous créez un cada mon
nom instantanément on dit oui alors
demandé qu'est ce qui arrive ça marche
pas 400 dollars c'est quand même cher
[Musique]
ça passe toujours nous avons un
collectif de médecins en fonction au
québec
on va essayer d'appeler l'arnacoeur en
question on dirait qu'il veut pas me
donner plus d'informations que sa part
écrit peut-être que si on le confronte
il va nous en dire un peu plus
bonjour
je parle bien avec médecin pour la
liberté
oui mon nom et nicolas de rosa je suis
journaliste pour radio canada au canada
puis je voulais savoir pourquoi vous en
ac et des gens ont essayé de vendre des
faux passeports d'accident
c'est pas de la mac
comment ça
et vous est basée au cameroun ces sommes
[Musique]
parce que votre page facebook si vous
êtes basé au cameroun
fait que ces joutes si je vous demande
de me faire une passe avec un nom
spécifique vous me voyez ça
d'accord
je
[Musique]
suis ok merci
nous avons finalement décidé d'aller au
bout de l'expérience et de commander un
faux passeport vaccinale au nom d'alexis
parce qu'il était impossible pour nous
déterminer avec certitude qu'il
s'agissait d'une arnaque après tout le
vendeur s'est défendu ardemment lors de
notre confrontation après s'être entendu
avec lui en négociant le prix à la
baisse il a promis de nous envoyer le
parti par le lendemain matin 24 heures
plus tard nous avions toujours rien reçu
après avoir contacté à nouveau le
vendeur et nous envoyer un code qr
caviardé au nom d'alexis en exigeant
davantage d'argent pour l'avoir
immédiatement ou de patienter encore
nous avons choisi de patienter et cinq
jours plus tard nous n'avons toujours
pas reçu de code qr donc jusqu'à preuve
du contraire c'est une arnaque
alors nicolas on s'entend que tout cela
se passe dans l'univers dans l'espace
facebook qui dotés de règles d'un homme
qui dans ce cas ci sur bafouille ben
exactement il ya toutes sortes de règles
qui encadrent la publicité sur facebook
notamment les arnaques sont interdites
la fausse publicité est interdite donc
déjà là des règles qui sont bafoués mais
surtout avec la gobbi 19le ya toutes
sortes de publicité qui ont été bannis
par facebook l'an dernier notamment en
ce qui a trait à des défauts sur des
choses comme ça mais aussi d'autres
choses qui nous permet de contourner les
règles sanitaires de que 19 y sont
bannis de facebook donc ces publicités
de la bafoue toutes sortes de noms
comment ça peut se faire comment ça peut
se produire ça mais techniquement
publicités facebook doivent être
approuvées par la plate forme et ça
pouvait par de l'intelligence
artificielle
donc c'est étrange c'est que l'on parle
de co vide on se dirait qu'idéalement un
humain devrait garder ces peuples sont
conformes aux normes des plateformes la
danse que si sa part été fait mais la
réalité c'est que il ya très peu de
modérateur pour les publicités facebook
donc ça fait en sorte que la plupart
même qui sont illégales ou qui bafoue
les règles mais elle passe inaperçue et
tout ça amène de l'eau au moulin à des
discours comme celui de francis le guen
qui est cette lanceuse d' alerte qui à
visière levée a dénoncé son ancien
employeur facebook en disant que la
compagnie le géant facebook faisait
passer des profits avant la sécurité ben
exactement et madame morgan c'est pas la
première à dire ça en fait déjà il ya
plusieurs années des employés de
facebook disait à bosse film you ce que
justement ce qui a trait aux publicités
les profits sont plus importants que la
sécurité c'est des personnes à
l'extérieur de la compagnie dont des
contractants qui s'occupe des publicités
et qui ont très peu d'incitatifs à agir
donc vraiment seulement cédé des
publicités qui endommageraient
l'aspect financier de facebook leur
profil c'est là qu'on les retire plus
souvent qu'autrement ce que disaient les
employés de facebook à beauceville news
sous le couvert de l'anonymat donc on
voit qu encore dans ce cas ci ben les
profits partir de sécurité
d'utilisateurs et surtout la sas est une
arnaque parmi tant d'autres mais la
réalité c'est qu'il ya tellement d'arnac
sur facebook et ça fait en sorte que la
plateforme mac sont un terreau fertile
pose en art comme celle là la plateforme
facebook a supprimé les pages de
médecins pour la liberté après que nous
l'ayons contacter les publicités et est
en ligne depuis au moins deux semaines
au québec qui les pages et est aussi
active auprès des auditoires français et
belges le réseau social n'a pas voulu
nous expliquer pourquoi les publicités
sont passés sous son radar bien qu'elle
enfreignait clairement plusieurs règles